thank you
[Music]
okay been a lot of hooting and hollering
in the tuber scum Community
That's What I Call tubers in general
tubers come it's been a long time since
we got into some tuber scandals well
yeah so there's a new trend that I
thought we would have an interesting
angle on which is there's a hell of a
lot of family vlogging hate out there
now have you guys seen that why because
they're kind of like exploitative people
are saying it's exactly people saying
it's exploitative the kid doesn't have
consent oh and what's up with that so I
thought we have a unique perspective
obviously I've seen it happen in real
life like uh remember we went to
playlist live in Florida all right we're
all hanging out and I remember it was
like 11 o'clock at night and there was a
baby still crawling on the floor and
then the parent was just with the Vlog
camera still vlogging I got the shot and
I was like it's [__] 11 o'clock at
night that's [__] crazy oh is that
when there was like we were at that
party and the music was like damn
there's all these kids on the Dance
Floor I'm like what the [__] it's like 2
A.M and there's like eight-year-olds
[__] bopping it yeah I'm like good
b-roll though I'm so glad you guys got
to see that because it is a fascinating
world that not many people get to see
what it is because it's different from
VidCon it's the same [__] when I thought
about Playlist Live I thought it was
going to be like more like VidCon but
it's I think it was different because
I didn't see like like tick tockers and
all that like that was the beginning
that was like the beginning of that yeah
yeah kids yeah well there was the
whatever the last generation was it was
um Vines I believe well the vine stars
were there yeah but yeah it was all that
it was it's it's the same thing as
VidCon but it's just in Florida and the
there's there's more old school tubers
there whereas VidCon has more of like
the current crop and all that kind of
stuff oh
interesting what do you think about
family Vlog stuff I don't get why people
dude first of all everyone's dramatic
about everything now yeah you know like
a hundred years ago your dad would take
you into a [__] coal mine
okay and you were thankful that you
could eat at night yeah and like maybe
even [__] breathe without coughing or
some [__] and nowadays people are like
this is so exploitative I'm like bro go
look at some pictures of miners kids
with [__] soot all over all over the
face like four inches all over their
face they look like grown men at seven
years old [__] smoking a cigarette
yeah they're all looking at the camera
like the [__] and you're like these are
children very strong forms you know yeah
they're not going to school it's all day
[__] taking a picture they die at 55.
people want to say it's child labor yeah
you got a [__] kid oh you're putting
a camera in a kid's face they don't they
don't know what's going on they have
extravagant birthday parties and they're
like they're exploiting them yeah
exactly and then you get the kid look at
what BART did to his kid's life he gives
them a [__] Ford Expedition little
Power Wheels
hahaha
are you kidding me like like what yeah
what is like
his like documenting his life given
taika a lot of cool [__]
yeah I don't get it yeah meanwhile some
other kid the X-ray can't even show what
his lungs look like because it's blocked
I'm saying puss that's still that still
exists there's still countries where the
whole family works from like the time
that the kid's born just about yeah also
going to be different if like the child
really didn't want to be on camera like
it wasn't about it wasn't having fun you
know yeah yeah like that's a different
thing like they're actively forcing
their kid to be on camera just for the
video that's something that where that's
something we're really conscious of
because we know for sure if we have
taika in a video and in the thumbnail
the video will do much better but then I
think our approach to Vlog has always
been more like let's capture memories
for ourselves and so it's actually me
and Jill's life and if taika comes into
it then it's happens organically through
our narrative so like taiko's not the
star so there's times where it's like
Tyga's not in any of our family videos
because he's off doing whatever he wants
to do and then there's time so literally
go hey papa open the camera I'm gonna
talk to it like yeah he has something to
say oh my God I just go like you don't
have the [__] start buddy
a lot of them started coming out where
like it was like it was like kind of
[__] up like the real the reality of
like because these wholesome dads were
just [__] railing all the fans
railing the fans and then like all this
controversy was coming out and then I
thought that pre-covered was already
shot there's a whole new generation of
them and I think I thought the old ones
are gone yeah somebody like Shay cross
still at it yeah that even that examples
like that when [__] goes bad it [__]
boosts the other guys because the market
share goes down and then they get to say
we're not like that and then everyone
gravitates to the people who are good
now there are some [__] up things that
happen right like the whole like um the
parents were pranking their kids like it
was going crazy when that Philly got
taken away they're they're wilding out
really [__]
Phil got
I'm good um parents were were like fake
like scaring their kids like actually
scaring them yeah the prank ones
pranking them and all kinds of really
like it was like mental torture there's
like footage of the kids saying like I
don't want to do this and [__] and
somehow that still made the edit I would
have edit that [__] out yeah
oh he's just being a rascal yeah
mistakes were made contact clues were
given and I think Phil helped put it all
together yeah Philly D started covering
it like really intensely one YouTube
channel or is it like a bunch of
different ones that he could it was a
couple of them but there was one in
particular that like went down for this
big time yeah and then there's a couple
years in the bridge of it got child
services to take a closer look and they
yanked the kids out oh [__] and Phil's a
dad so he's like pretty militant like
that which I can't I can respect that
was the villain origin story of that guy
he was like fool yeah big time I
wouldn't be surprised I do try to find
him or some [__] that guy was pissed
yeah that's scary what do you think
about family vlogging job
I think it depends
nice
by the way this is we're doing an
hour-long podcast on this right now so
this is JK podcast so this is uh This Is
overtime so I like Bart said though I've
seen I've seen people that we've known
where like they're just not in real life
they're like not a loving family at all
but they got a [__] brand you or
something to do so they go
hey guys yeah well [__] if you want
to be a [__] perfect couple like us I
[__] don't like that at all because I
just think like you're you're deceiving
your fan base like crazy and that's what
I think fans are saying is like hey you
painted this picture of a perfect family
I aspire to be like you guys you gave me
so much hope that this exists in the
world and then you [__] shattered it
by being a fraud you deceived me and I
think that's what people out there are
getting mad at and I think that's legit
on the flip side
if they want to document their lives
because vlogging is basically video
diaries and if you want to do that on a
small scale like and and it's for your
families because that's how people did
originally Vlog it's journaling through
video right and it was meant for like
your circle of friends or whatever who
wanted to tune in and it just got bigger
and bigger and bigger so I'm like I
don't know man where's the fine line
behind just creating content videos that
are just now being posted yeah
no nothing yeah yeah
yeah where's the intro dad Zooms in on
the microwave uh clock yeah to document
the time and it's flashing like that oh
God it's on the bottom dad Jesus since
the lens cap is still on Dad uh
Christmas is over here actually Buckhead
yeah
using a child too if they're having this
perfect family life on camera and then
the camera turns off and now this child
is in a different reality
yeah maybe the kid wants to always be
vlogging them
there I get to be all like yeah yeah
yeah
I love that [__] [__] reach down
copper ass and [__] like that and I know
she [__] is hating me
on the flip side too though what if you
know some people just live miserable
lives and they want to take down people
that appear happy that's very true so it
might be that there's these this sweet
little family is authentic and they're
just documenting their lives and they're
having fun not knowing what kind of evil
[__] are out there and they're just
constantly bombarded being accused of
being a fake family you know like I I
don't know it's just a it's just a weird
space being in entertainment I like
going on family channels and being like
you guys are a [__] fake family fake
family [__] you I do a fake
report for terrorism fake this is all
fake fake fake fake fake
I'm like the kids are fake and I'm like
the kids are gay yeah the dad is gay
fake and gay holy [__] kids are [__]
you know I'm just saying random stuff
too yeah because I bet that's [__] up
too though I bet somebody some of the
comments on there are just wild dude
what makes that person
oh wait let me write this so I'm not
logged in hold on yeah
oh wait
so you're gonna so you're just gonna
feed your kid red 40 what a piece of
[__] process
hahaha
but this this topic makes parts so
incredible he's like
okay
Steve do you personally know
um like a family vlogger that you know
something about them that the public
doesn't I did but then
you know it kind of came out anyway but
it came out a different way than I
thought because like you know I don't
want to cause anything I don't want to
like start anything or kick anything up
because I really like this guy yeah but
um yeah I'll just won't name the names
but yeah
um I knew that he had a problem
and then it came out in a different way
and I was like oh I didn't know you had
that problem that's interesting oh so
it's a different problem but then the
good thing I think is that the fans
actually were really mature
um someone really disappointed obviously
but he let people down and he owned it
yeah and then um you know he kind of did
like a recovery like tour like like took
time to rebuild his life and then um you
know I think he's came out on the other
end okay so yeah but but I definitely
remember you know
genuinely loving the guy and being like
this guy's a great guy love him I didn't
know he had that going on yeah um and it
was like oh dang that sucks for him but
it's not my life right yeah but dude
there's a lot of them there is I think
being in YouTube or just in
entertainment in general
it's kind of weird like watching it all
happen and then you see their fans and
you're like I feel so bad for you people
bro people have no [__] idea
how crazy some of those YouTube [__] is
yeah they have no clue I remember being
at VidCon or no I was a playlist and I
remember seeing like a tuber
full-on trying to get like a girl's
phone number and she was like I mean I
don't know how old she was like I didn't
[__] check her ID but I'm like she
looked 12. this [__] looks [__] like
not 18 exactly or maybe she's 19 but she
looks young as [__] bro and you're like
30 dude yeah like yeah kind of wild [__]
well
uh yeah we've seen a lot of that but
I'll never knock yeah and I'll never
tell the police anything not kidding
there's nothing like there's nothing set
there's nothing
that's the most common one probably yeah
when it comes to family channels I would
say like
it depends I think what's scary about
the approach because I've seen like a
whole like different Spectrum you know
I've seen we know what goes on behind
the scenes is I feel like for us the way
that we because I if I already know what
channel I would start for taika I would
start a gaming channel where he's doing
a commentary because him even just
getting haircuts and him playing
Minecraft he says the funniest [__] and
I'm like dude this [__] would go viral
like crazy and I tell the show my butt
but he's like really really fun but I
also know like once something becomes a
actual operation yeah like me seeing
other YouTubers where the couples got
into a fight but now they have a Samsung
brand deal so they have to pretend to
lovey-dovey to sell a [__] vacuum or
some [__] I know those things happen
right so like because I know that [__]
happens when you have a kid and you have
a channel and it's an operation you're
not immune to that there's gonna be a
time where in the middle of me
disciplining taika or he didn't do good
at school or something like that I'm
like oh [__] we got this brand deal that
we have to do not have to put on a
headset on the video so it's like this
very weird artificial world so we're
lying there yeah so for us I think we
approach it with childhood first we want
to make sure we preserve the family and
the childhood first and if he ever comes
to me like hey my friends have a YouTube
channel can I do have a YouTube channel
okay I'll help you this is what I've
been doing for the last 10 years but I
don't want to be the person with the
carrot on the stick going this is what
you should do I want it to be led by him
so that's kind of like our approach
whereas like when I look at some of the
other uh channels where there's really
kid heavy it makes me kind of scared the
type of Dynamics they have to balance
because who knows what that yeah who
knows how that changes yeah even like
just in in commercials like in Hollywood
and stuff like that right yeah kids
could be throwing a tantrum yeah just
like bad behavior but dude there's
Millions on the line for this thing we
need him to [__] act we need him to
throw stop his tantrum so there's people
that like were like yeah I had to pull
my kid out because the way that they
were treating them it was like a [__]
royal God yeah that was like what do you
want what do you want uh you want
chocolate yeah you want a puppy you want
this we'll do this right now we'll do it
for you and then like they [__] like
oh [__] yeah
yeah and then and then so they're just
like on a high all the time because it's
like how do we keep these kids pumped up
on a high so they're acting they're
creating they're happy they're not
throwing Tantrums they're reading their
lines so it's like
that to me is the [__] up part is like
yeah there is a lot of exploitation
going on yeah but at the same time if
you're making millions for your family
shut the [__] up and make that money
like like Ryan's world like that kid
that's the thing I always think about
because like the kids he does all the
toy reviews but I'm sure when the
parents started the [__] Channel
there's like 30 million a year or
something yeah like I bet they didn't
think it was gonna lead to what he's
doing like right because I'm sure he's
doing TV he's doing YouTube he's doing
how old is he now he's got toys in
Target yeah like I see his face at
Target you know yeah and you're like
holy [__] this kid is a beast that's the
scariest thing because I've seen lots of
interviews with his parents explaining
what their process is and they talk
about how like oh you know we make sure
it's something that he wants to do it's
like but you guys have been doing this
for over a decade or some [__] so like
30 ml a year
like it's been his idea every [__]
year because I remember being a kid and
changing my goddamn mind all the time
and it's and it the thing is like I'm
not doubting that like okay let's say
that they're telling the complete truth
with their Dynamic that's more [__]
valuable than anything they've ever done
share what the [__] you did as a parent
yeah yeah because that's the Goldberg
and you found something so early yes
sell parenting classes and you were able
to maintain a healthy method right but
do you think they sat there and like
waiting for him to say something he's
like I want a toy Target
come on yeah
I haven't I know what I want I want to
try out my own twin Tark so Ryan we got
this opportunity from Target it's a
genius
oh my God I'm so glad
somebody came up with that idea on his
own do you guys remember John and Kate
Plus Eight yeah yeah you were here you
love them huh Heroes oh dude so my wife
has been showing me all his interviews
that he's been doing since like uh just
talking about how the whole process of
the TV show that [__] is crazy yeah bro
and he's just talking about how like
I think he was more on the side of
preserving their childhood and all that
he was like dude we can't be doing this
too much because I think it gotten out
of hand with a lot of brand deals and
ads and all that you don't have a normal
life anymore yeah and then the mom was
like no we're gonna go all in TV and he
he says she's like a narcissist did you
see when that did you see when she was
mad at him for breathing yeah yeah that
[__] happened to me before and then you
see that no way someone got mad at me
for breathing what the [__] what was the
situation that's a situation that she
hated him yeah yeah
I wasn't even with this no we're not
we're not even with each other
oh just a person no I was just listening
to people talk in a circle and I'm just
like
foreign
because I think I drank too much coffee
and I was having like coffee caffeine
anxiety yeah yeah just just like a nice
deep breath like yeah like that doing
that take a deep one and then later on I
got pulled to the side I have a
conversation and then they're like I
don't appreciate you [__] doing that
and I'm like what did I do who said this
say their name and then they're like say
their [__] name you know like I know
you were disappointed I know you didn't
you didn't you were like thinking about
me and you were disappointed in me and
you you didn't like this and I'm just
like heard of I mean
this is the weirdest conversation I've
ever had and I'm all like how the [__]
do you even read my mind because yes I
wasn't I'm just kidding no I was like I
was like
how did you even come up with this
imagination how'd you make this about
you and it becomes fact in your brain
and then you're confronting me to
apologize
for something that I didn't even think
or do did you go
oh that's about this that's about this
before that's not c c that's what you do
dude sounds really angry yeah yeah but
this is mentally a person
that that clip who was this male that
clip was it's like that wow it's like
it's like that John that you saw it
right yeah where he's just like
[__] being a dude just blanking out
she goes why are you doing that like why
are you breathing why are you breathing
so hard like you don't have to breathe
so [__] hard and she imitates him and
you're like oh that's my tellity
yeah but you're getting 40K an episode
[__] they were the first they
were the first [__] like family Vlog
and get your ass on camera
that's like the brand deal thing if
couples are mad at each other yeah they
have to keep recorded a couple brand
deals when we're [__] pissing each
other that happens but
you guys you guys pissed at each other's
relatively healthy yeah it we're it's
very productive and we off and we often
talk about it afterwards like on our
podcast even so it's really I mean
there's a difference between fighting
and actually couples being disgusted and
hating because nothing's wrong with
being mad at each other or fighting
that's how you figure relationship and
actually hating is yes I think to me
it's you guys actually fight on camera
and off camera and it's funny but you
still love each other right like I don't
like fraudulent relationships where you
pretend to being this perfect couple
and then the world looks at you and goes
bad goals one day I wanna I wanna be
like that and then you're you're also
giving advice and you're also like yeah
if that makes me sick you know that
actually happened to us recently we were
doing a podcast episode right and
someone's like hey what do I do me and
my husband haven't been [__] and we
were like we ain't been [__] dude
we're like we're like Nikki started
doing the World Series of Poker like
she's so stressed out and she we ain't
[__] right now like a little straight
up we'll tell you but that's what I like
about me and Nikki's relationship we
don't have to be all guarded about [__]
we're like no hey we ain't [__] like
that's awesome
I did get it in recently oh yeah boy
that's the World Series just chilling
out it's over because the World Series
ended we've seriously banged the next
but not the big a though
imagine every time you guys see Nikki
you start doing these little clues about
anal about how she should probably do
animals did you do it yet did you do it
yet nope all right hey have you seen
this book on like how taking anal is not
that bad
that's the title it's like wow Nick's
really like subversive with this
suggestion
[Music]
foreign
okay